for the past few years Cadillac has been
working hard to change it has moved its
headquarters to New York City sponsored
fashion shows and flown the press and
VIPs to product lunches in Dubai more
importantly and it started making cars
like the CTSV which are incredibly fast
and powerful on the road the brand is
trying to shake off that fuddy-duddy
image the thing is those old Cadillacs
were rad the Fleetwood the Calais and
the series 60 and 63 lines were full of
style they meant something and when I
was in Detroit recently I went for a
drive down Cadillacs memory lane
that's when I met this 1967 Cadillac
DeVille it's a dream boat painted in
Persian ivory with snow-white seats on
the inside this is the signature sedan
that caddy made from 1946 to 2006 it
takes its name from the French term
Deville or of the town so as you might
expect this is a car for cruising around
town when it was introduced it was the
largest car in the model range at the
time checking in at more than eighteen
feet from tip to trunk this is
definitely the longest car I've driven
but it feels like you're on a cloud you
just float along kind of like a figure
skater on ice it's made totally out of
metal sculpted into boat like elegance
and festooned with luxury the front
grille looks like a silver rack set with
diamonds at each end in 1967 the car had
an eight cylinder 340 horsepower engine
that still today runs as smoothly as it
did when it was first born these days
you can buy one in perfect working order
for about 20 grand which is a nice
appreciation considering the fact that
they cost about five thousand when they
first came out but when you drive it
you'll feel way more posh than that the
two bench seats are smooth and plush the
steering wheel is as thin as a reed and
makes you feel like a real lady it's a
little different than how caddy is
branding itself today what with that
move toward a more aggressive edgy ride
but the desire to give drivers a strong
sense of style still remains the same
you